amici miei non potevo dirvi niente
perché mi è stato detto sito di stare
zitto se no ti facciamo un mazzo così
quindi sono stato zitto
c'è una novità importante tutti noi che
seguiamo youtube da una vita
conosciamolo youtube rewind cos'è lo
youtube rewind praticamente youtube ogni
anno fa un mash up delle tendenze che
sono andate durante l'anno che e passato
in vita tra i topi youtuber nel mondo a
partecipare in questo video mash up che
se ne fa un appunto l'anno e si chiama
youtube rewind quest'anno hanno chiamato
me la prima volta credo che un italiano
viene chiamato in un wine quindi per me
è proprio ciò che figata incredibile
quindi sono andato a londra
ciò la maglietta anche a tema per fare
le riprese di youtube rewind e ho fatto
un po di backstage youtube rewind è
uscito già da un paio di giorni io sono
stato chiamato insieme ad altri sei o
sette youtubers a fare un balletto in
slow motion
vabbè già questa cosa è strana e sapete
cos'è ancora più strano che il balletto
era su fort night
ok vabbè vi lascio ai backstage di
londra buona visione
allora ragazzi mi sono svegliato che
siamo in centro a milano piazza del
duomo sono col mio amico tamarro che
time is it sa solo questo e michele dove
siamo a londra ok se non londra non ho
bloccato sulla ero perché mi vergogno
siamo fuori dal nostro tel
se non sappiamo neanche se possiamo dire
perché siamo qua non possiamo non
sappiamo se possiamo dire perché se
ancora perché il top secret
dai non possono dire è questo il nostro
hotel adesso entriamo vediamo come siamo
a londra parole merlino marino parla
sempre uguale in bravissimo vabbè dai
tiravo le locazioni che si chiederanno
cosa veramente periti c'è più british di
questa cosa
forse c'è solo la reggina dunque ho
notato che salendo le scale mi aspettavo
non so quanta istanze invece no ci sono
porte chiuse il padre ma ci sono gli
ascensori ma scusami sai te che vorrei
fare primi non c'erano le gli ascensori
torto sia un'altra porta siccome molti
di voi mi tartassano il birillo quello
che registra compreso che non mi faccio
più il salto sul letto con dentro nel
nello bene sante l'hotel oggi lo
facciamo
prima vediamo come la scavolini è molle
[Musica]
wow senza chiudere qualche volta mi va
bene c'è il regalino ci regalino che
hanno portato subito questo abbiamo una
guardia a keba luce solare perché ci ha
lasciato
ma non è dell'hotel quello di dicembre
dati esatto quelli nominati le campagne
la madonna io dormo nella vasca grazie
quando un giorno solo aspetta la
facciamo in regalo di benvenuto e alieni
e mio un evia evian chiara ferrania un
tuo amico e piano ma non c'è chi la
ferragni starna brinca per carattere e
d'urto la crema soft della nivea un po
perché dico il muro era un box il più
bello della storia un souvenir che si è
sicuramente riciclerà regalando il crudo
non abbiamo assolutamente compra
esperienza che sono già dato un parente
stretto al quale ho regalato questo non
è quello che ti ho regalato l'ho
comprato qui io a parte permetterà bello
che l'ha comprata uguale
centri un televisore questo zio questo
in tv specchio vai esistere
bellissimo secondo me questo lo puoi
portare via scandone milioni di euro
ho allora 12 ore che mi dici ciò fare
ciò fame è finito nou dove si è messo lo
re stavolta hai visto si è visto lo re
ancora non è come la nostra
ogni volta che andiamo in viaggio si
imbosca floor e o eccolo o co te ne stai
facendo
cosa stai facendo ha capito secondo me
pensano che hai vinto un buono per
venire qua perché 5 e che non parla ed è
coperto con una coccarda puzza commento
caldo sono meno 26 gradi commento a
caldo un nas o che ragazzo ho visto la
hanno una scheda tecnica dove catalogano
gli youtuber presenti r white noi questa
scena di ottobre wine ci sono anche io
ovviamente ve la faccio vedere allora
questa è la prima pagina sono questi
ragazzi qua però le forti knight no e
poi c'è la pagina dopo noi ci sono anche
io
uno fa ridere che mi ha messo st foto
perché questa foto tra tutte perché
quella con la coppola di don matteo e
poi il ruolo fornai perché non gioco a
four nights va bene
la gamma
un prato sta roba di 5 euro dai gemelli
sbagliarmi sempre che dice boot perché
non vi vede ok ragazzi apparentemente
qui dove girano youtube rewind non so se
l'avete mai visto youtube rewind e
dovremo registrare qua a quanto pare
qualcosa sul forte cioè senza noi
facciamo una parte dello rewind ore si
parla di forno e cioè il trend di fornai
io che ho giocato a farne due volte e
tutti bloccano la videocamera
io da bravo youtuber a 5 milioni col
telefono
dunque è bellissimo e pieno di fumo
sembra se ne andò tutto a fuoco tra sono
fumi fake fighissimo il riposo del
guerriero bene come cento forte ma no io
nei videogiochi mi incavolo sempre
perché la gente quando corre dopo due
secondi che tuorli del gioco il tipo di
stampante e decimi ma corri quest'estate
al mcdonald's moli capisco un sacco
gratis e lì è spiaciuto degli insultati
[Musica]
quindi ragazzi abbiamo finito la
giornata è stata veramente lunga però
abbiamo ballato tutta la mattina io che
ballo mi conoscete che ecco io penso di
essere una delle persone al mondo più
negate a ballare eppure mi fanno ballare
ovunque just dance quality wines emilio
ballo ballo schifo mi fanno allarmi
grazie a dio non canto comunque qua
siamo di un lago non so bene dove siamo
figli siamo in nei dintorni di londra
però vabbè stiamo per riprendere l'aereo
per ritornare nella buona milano è stata
una bella giornata ha conosciuto un
sacco di persone leskovac via ragazzi
siamo a londra
come di consueto ogni volta che vado all
on devo controllare se c'è la mia
bevanda però l'hanno tolta e anni che
non c'è fini non penso anche conosciuti
a los angeles che son passati la vado a
vedere non c'è troviamo però non ci
credo incredibile tratta subito de vries
20 gen
stringi j voi ragazzi questo è un
placement perché questa roba anche un pò
schifo però la figc j
è mia io devo comprare tutto il bancale
nomi e quindi pensa la pretty jane non
la trovo da tre anni sono dovuti venire
a londra per cercato minuti per queste
realtà non per gli ato per i wine grazie
ciao
quindi ragazzi questo era il video
backstage di londra penso che non potrei
essere più orgoglioso del traguardo che
abbiamo raggiunto
non parlo solo gli iscritti parlo
proprio di essere arrivati ad un certo
punto io non mi sento mai arrivato però
ogni volta che mi guardi indietro dico
cavolo quanto fatto per me volare a
londra per un giorno che questo stato un
giorno solo
ho dormito una notte sola e stato
fantastico per poter partecipare al al
rewind che per me il rewind è come un
film ogni anno me lo vivo e dico cavolo
che figata rewind e quest'anno noi
chiamato me è fighissimo io guardavo
arrivando ancora prima di farlo youtube
e quindi sono proprio orgoglioso di cio
grazie ragazzi anche perché se non fosse
stato davvero per voi non sarei non
sarei mai arrivato lì quindi grazie io
vi lascio in conclusione del video con
un mash up di social face m ci vediamo a
un prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]
ciao